quatre coins du monde les salles
disparaissent
[Musique]
en afrique elles sont devenues des
décharges publiques où l'on vient uriné
sur des kilomètres de pellicule qui
jonchent le sol
en russie les films sont malmenés par le
pouvoir et les bobines jeter à la
poubelle
en inde le cinéma est toujour glorifier
mais loin des grandes villes il ne reste
que le satellite pour se faire une toile
sur petit écran
aux états unis on s'enferme dans des
complexes aseptisé en se goinfrant de
pop corn et de sodas
le parlant aurait tué le muet
[Musique]
la couleur aurait tué le noir et blanc
aujourd'hui le numérique tuerait le 35
mm et internet et les dvd la magie des
grands écrans
[Musique]
sont construites dans tout le pays par
les cinq plus gros studios de l'époque
200 rien qu'à new york
[Musique]
des lieux sublimes aujourd'hui englouti
en attente d'être restaurés ou
transformées
un véritable patrimoine historique celui
de l'âge d'or du cinéma américain dans
une banlieue se cache l'un de ces
titanic craig morrison est architecte il
répertorie et cherche à préserver ses
movie palace comme on les appelle ici
c'est lui qui me fait découvrir ce lieu
sacré dissimulé derrière une boutique de
vêtements bon marché
ça c'est le destin de beaucoup de grands
cinémas aux états unis ce
[Musique]
qui était une très grande ville la plus
grande du new jersey mais lorsqu'elle a
été supplanté par manhattan cette
banlieue est devenue très dangereuse
les gens ne voulaient plus venir ici on
préférait alors rester près de chez soi
aller au cinéma après sa maison c'est
comme ça que ce genre de cinéma a été
fermé
construit en 1923 avec ses deux salles
l'une au dessus de l'autre le proctor
fut le premier multiplex new yorkais son
histoire s'est arrêtée en 1960
à l'autre bout de la ville le lendemain
fi hadha est en cours de restauration et
ouvrira à nouveau ses portes
prochainement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
également regarder tous ces fauteuils
imaginez 2500 personnes assises ici deux
fois par soir cela faisait vingt mille
spectateurs chaque semaine cette ville
était vraiment vivant
essayez de vous plonger à l'époque où
tous ces bâtiments était flambant neuf à
ce moment là il n'y avait pas de
télévision pas d'internet
est allé au cinéma c'était la seule
chose à faire
alors quand les gens venaient ici
c'était comme aller au château de
versailles
[Musique]
dans le quartier juif de brooklyn le
cinéma universal a été transformé en
magasin de meubles depuis 1973 il ne
sert plus car entreposer des chaises
sous plastique
même complètement défoncée et rouillée
ces vaisseaux ont étrangement survécu au
temps et à la pression immobilière de la
ville
[Musique]
me voici en inde
l'autre pays du cinéma avec ses films
inenvisageable ailleurs que là bas
[Musique]
le pays aux douze mille salles et aux 14
millions de spectateurs par jour voir un
film ici c'est plus qu'un devoir
c'est le quotidien d'un peuple qui
oublie la dureté de la vie à travers des
ballets synchronisée dégoulinant de
taureaux les
mais loin de calcutta et de ces files
interminables devant les temples
bollywoodien pas de grand écran mais des
dvd qui projette des images piratés sur
des télés fatigué
alors même dans les endroits les plus
secrets on trouve des moyens pour
projeter des films
guéret
regard
[Musique]
j'accompagne ravi son projecteur et ses
bobines de 35 mm avec lui le septième
art investi les méandres du gange là où
certains n'ont jamais vu de film
[Musique]
s'il pleut il faudra tout enlever
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici les villageois n'ont pas la
possibilité de se divertir alors les
gens restent chez eux et regarde plutôt
la télé ou des dvd à parcey n'y a rien
d'autre à faire au moment des fêtes
religieuses ils vont au temple et c'est
aussi l'occasion de voir un film en
plein air sur un grand écran ainsi le
cinéma c'est comme une fête religieuse
si on veut aller au cinéma il faut aller
jusqu à calcutta le voyage coûte cher
entre 80 et 90 roupies les gens d'ici
n'ont pas les moyens alors c'est bien
que le cinéma de calcutta viennent à eux
on est super contents que cinéma soit là
il ne vient qu'au moment des festivités
ici on a hâte de voir un film d'action
sur grand écran
ici tout le monde attend ça avec
impatience
ça nous change j'espère que ce soir il y
aura plein de bagarre dans le film car
c'est ce que je peux faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la tournée des villages continuent en
afrique
[Musique]
vous voulez vous
passer
[Musique]
au sénégal qui ne compte plus que dix
salles en activité amadou ndo de
l'association image et vie sillonnent
les villages avec son micro son écran
gonflable et une mission donner aux
jeunes le goût du cinéma
[Musique]
oui on a fait l'essentiel on a sillonné
quelques duels et puis voilà pour leur
annoncer la tenue de la projection de
films inédits du coeur en tout cas voilà
c'est ça parce que bon quand on
travaille il faut de la passion il faut
aimer ce que l'on fait et c'est le cas
chez moi
[Musique]
la majorité des gens se disent ils ne
sont jamais entrés dans une salle de
cinéma donc il nous voit film qu'à
travers la télévision
j'étais encore petit c'était vraiment le
loisir le mieux partagé dakar est
partout au sénégal 1 parce que dans
toutes les grandes villes y avait une
salle au moins une salle on veut garder
une fois de voir même cinq fois parce
que les gens aimaient le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
waouh ça va mal comme cali salam
aleikoum maquiller salam aleikoum à nyon
fille super nos festivals - festival de
cinéma image et vie ouais édition
spéciale faire attention et écrit mon
fils caché de plumes l'avoir amené
relève l'obédience l'ombre de madame
hadja mariama
penda
les rennais ont pu la terminer bonnes
opinions
[Musique]
et
vous
ok
[Musique]
ça crois que tu es à venir manger du
fluide jours
en général quand tu tant pis pour lui
cette façon c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas je ne vais pas te cacher
je suis à nouveau célibataire
explique pourtant c'est arrivé une et en
l'ayant pas
disons que
j'ai su prix avec une autre femme et
j'ai décidé qu'on en reste là aussi peu
le jour tout trouvera un seul mec dans
ce pays ne tombe pas sa compagne
présente le mois
factuellement sont le secret
je
si le cinéma n'est plus dans les salles
il se cache dans les rues sombres et
jaune de dakar où la nuit il règne une
étrange atmosphère qui inspire des
contes des légendes des tragédies des
films
[Musique]
alors on réalise à quel point ce
continent est puissamment
cinématographique
waouh par les
quand on
non
oh
[Musique]
me voici en russie à moscou
belle riche et des quatiers à la fois
avec des airs tristes deux pays entre
deux mondes
[Musique]
une ville où vladimir poutine n'hésite
pas à s'afficher en grand sur la
devanture d'un énorme multiplex façon
ivan le terrible qui impose clairement
que le cinéma ici c'est une affaire
d'état
[Musique]
et
dans les années 20 lénine avait inventé
le 6 mai train pour faire circuler des
films de propagande dans les endroits
les plus reculés du pays
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le parti de poutine russie
unie a repris le principe en déployant
300 petits soldats à travers toutes les
campagnes
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de samarra à la
frontière du kazakhstan il ne se passe
rien un endroit oublier perdu un no
man's land blanc ici jamais de cinéma
sauf en cette période électorale avec le
poutinien réseau cinéma du populo
soit une voiture deux filles
[Musique]
et un écran
l'instruction what i télé qu'il réussit
chasse au scoop space et bouscotte paca
ce film
3d
monsieur chinois vous chez le dentiste
soutient georges
moustaki tout ça ici des films du square
ou trois bonnes mais si bordeaux gagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
on se méfie du squat ou de
celui-ci connaissons
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons montrer aux
habitants du village le film la
forteresse de brest ça parle des débuts
de la grande guerre patriotique sur le
territoire de l'urss et de la ville
héroïque de brest litovsk qui a subi la
première attaque de la part des troupes
nazies
mais avant ça nous allons projeter un
petit film de propagande
ou est ce que c'est
[Musique]
à
cf dix personnes
ne se
soient sérieusement
[Musique]
et ce malgré une personne historiens
dynamiques sociales versées
[Musique]
à la fin de la projection chacun repart
avec son tract du parti
[Musique]
et une spectatrice a l'air très heureuse
les nullités
ackermann verniolle
[Musique]
mon voyage se poursuit en ouganda en
afrique de l'est
ce pays a été mutilée par un dictateur
fou il dit amin dada
qui s'était proclamé roi décosse une
tragédie porté à l'écran par d'autres il
fut un temps où ce pays était une terre
de cinéma hollywoodien là où john huston
y tourna african queen là où john ford
réalisa mogambo
[Musique]
alors pour oublier l'histoire et la
misère environnante
les ougandais se pressent dans les
grandes salles de cinéma de kampala
ici la salle et leur dernier refuge
l'endroit où l'on se rassemble en masse
pour vénérer un unique acteur aux
cheveux longs
[Musique]
voilà
à
jésus
avicii assez la salle au palais bethabet
[Musique]
ici les salles n'existe plus vraiment
elles ont toutes été transformée en
église
[Musique]
et comme dans toute bonne séance
il y a toujours le type qui donne
[Musique]
comme il n'y a plus de cinéma en ouganda
on a trouvé une solution les vidéos hall
des baraques sombre et étouffante
construites de bric et de broc équipés
d'une télé de banc et d'un vidéo jockey
qui traduit en langue locale les
dialogues des films étrangers 3000
salles vidéo foisonnent à tous les coins
de rue et dans tous les bidonvilles
un cinéma avec une autre voie
jing aux tabous là est le plus célèbre
des vies jace du pays cela fait plus de
vingt ans qu'il apporte hollywood dans
tous les villages
[Musique]
je traduis les films et j'utilise
différentes langues le soin lit le
l'ouganda
c'est pour ça que je travaille même en
dehors du pays
quand j'ai commencé je voyais ça comme
un amusement jusqu'à ce que je réalise
que je pouvais en faire mon métier
maintenant non seulement ça m'amuse mais
ça me permet surtout de nourrir toute ma
famille et des millions de gens
dépendent de moi dans mon pays
c'est devenu un gros business parce que
maintenant pour tous les gens du pays
c'est indispensable
cela permet vraiment aux gens de
s'instruire
[Applaudissements]
mais des mots vous rendre les films
divertissants on doit s'éclater et moi
j'adore regarder les films c'est pour ça
que je pense être le meilleur
ce soir on va voir un night and day
c'est un bon film électeurs est génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
n'étais
pas moi
[Musique]
s'agit-il
on
[Musique]
nous irions témoigne
los angeles la ville horizontale que ce
soit dans une piscine délavé évident le
long de ces freeway sur ses célèbres
murs peints los angeles suscite toujours
des imaginaires complexe et fait l'objet
de chaque côté de l'écran d'une
expérience esthétique stupéfiante
[Musique]
ici le trottoir c'est autant l'endroit
où l'on piétine les stars que celui où
l'on peut voir des films
dans le coeur baroque de la ville vivent
deux activistes révolutionnaire paulo
elisa
ce couple de réalisateurs enseigne le
cinéma aux jeunes du quartier et veut
offrir une vraie alternative aux films à
succès d'hollywood avec un vieux bus de
l'armée qui carbure aux
biographies gachi pas si tu sais mais
ici nous sommes dans le quartier de echo
park qui s'appelait avant endel et c'est
ici qu'est né le cinéma avec charlie
chaplin mack sennett
tous ses premiers films ont été fait ici
tout le monde pense que c'est à
hollywood que tout est né mais en fait
c'est vraiment en ce coin là
bon on n'annonce pas vraiment où on va
faire notre projection c'est très secret
on n'a pas de permis pour le fond ces
clandestins
aujourd'hui on va projeter un film et
croiser les doigts pour que les filles
ne viennent pas ça va aller
tu as déjà eu des problèmes
une fois un flic est venu et puis il
s'est assis et a regardé film
pour toi et c'est comme ça que tu
envisages de cinéma qui doit l'amener
aux gens de cette façon oui j'ai
longtemps travaillé pour limoux des et
j'ai détesté ça je déteste cette fois ci
avec le réalisateur d'un côté
l'assistante production de l'autre et
cette sensation d'être plus important
que l'autre attend je fais le tour
[Musique]
façon d'utiliser le cinéma on peut le
faire de manière très positive mais
aussi comme de la propagande comme du
lavage de cerveau moi je voulais montrer
autre chose des films qui racontent de
vraies histoires des histoires de
passion alors tous nos films sont
virulents politiquement mais ils sont
vrais fait avec amour et passion
au programme ce soir un film sur les
fantômes du célèbre hôtel ambassador là
où fut assassiné robert kennedy en 68 et
là où s'est déroulée la première
cérémonie des oscars en 29 essais juste
en face c'est que paolo installe son
micro signer
si vous voulez voir le film c'est
gratuit
[Musique]
merci pour votre patience est loin
l'autre cinéma ambulant est un peu
chaotique
que nous allons passer ensemble va être
très belle avec notre cinéma on célèbre
la ville et même si notre écran et petit
que la rue est bruyante que nous
flirtons avec le désastre et
l'illégalité nous sommes là pour
partager célébrer les centres jeunesse
comme un endroit où l'on peut vivre
[Musique]
non
je les
attends
quand je
[Musique]
à chaque pays ses monstres sacrés et son
cinéma légendaire là où l'on cultive la
nostalgie
à la périphérie de los angeles se trouve
le holt and music hall où l'on ne
projette que des films muets et des
comédies musicales réalisé avant 1954 un
endroit unique une plongée dans l'âge
d'or d'hollywood et loeb est
le propriétaire de ce monument des
années 20 c'est bill field
ici le vrai trésor c'est le vieux leader
qui siège devant l'écran un ordre
spécialement créé pour accompagner les
films muets
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à jouer de l'orgue quand
j'avais 12 ou 13 ans
je connaissais le propriétaire d'un
cinéma de los angeles
et
le patron était très heureux que
quelqu'un vienne et ça jouer de l'orgue
comme celle de mon histoire avec un jour
leader a commencé
beaucoup de sons étaient dédiées à des
scènes préciser le taux
et les sandinistes
[Musique]
il y avait aussi les scènes dans les
églises
[Musique]
pour les comédies c'était plutôt des
sont légers et rapides
[Musique]
vous voulez voir la collection de films
que j'ai à la cave
e
[Musique]
loulou avec louise brooks
c'est un film muet de l'oral et hardi
l'un de leurs premiers films
vous savez combien de films vous avez
ici
vous allez souvent cinéma
je suis allé voir alice au pays des
merveilles et alors c'est bien vous
l'avez vu en 3d
oui en effet car j'y suis allé avec
quelqu'un qui voulait le voir en 3d
mais pour moi ce n'était pas de la 3d
car il faut avoir deux yeux et je suis
aveugle d'un oeil
alors je ne peux pas voir en relief
je m'en suis rendu compte que très tard
quand les premiers films en 3d sont
sortis dans les années 50 j'y allais
souvent et j'entendais toujours les
autres crier et je ne comprenais pas
pour moi parce que je n'avais pas les
mêmes sensations que les autres
[Musique]
c'est un extrait du film qui a remporté
le premier oscar en 1929 c'est wings
[Musique]
je marche bien votre cinéma où c'est
compliqué parfois
toujours difficile
ouais pourquoi
wen
et bien
pour une seule raison
j'ai ouvert il ya plus de 40 ans la
moyenne d'âge du public étaient 50 ans
aime et vous pouvez imaginer où ils sont
maintenant
[Musique]
j'aime les deux films les films des
années 20 30 40
jeunes l'orgue je me l'entendre
j'adore l'atmosphère
vous savez à mon âge on est nostalgique
du temps bel endroit
je le recommande à tout le monde
[Musique]
oh
ok
aujourd'hui je vais vous jouez les airs
du film show boat et vous allez voir
c'est très beau j'espère que vous
apprécierez
[Musique]
tous
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis fauché plus d'argent sur le
contre
mais ça va je fais ce que j'aime et les
gens aiment venir ici
nos consciences
aujourd'hui à los angeles il n'y a plus
d'endroits comme fini si mobile on peut
voir ce genre de film haywire
alors c'est important d'être là
[Musique]
à moscou c'est au milieu d'un parc
d'attraction que se trouve un autre
cinéma mythique le kinopanorama
[Musique]
depuis 1957 rien n'a changé on y cultive
la mémoire d'un pays qui n'existe plus
sur douze écrans où sont projetés en
simultané des films à la gloire de
l'union soviétique
[Musique]
aux commandes de ce cinéma panoramique
deux femmes
une blonde
et une brune irina et natalia tous les
jours même pour un seul spectateur elle
charge avec fierté les douze projecteurs
[Musique]
vous savez je fais ça de manière
mécanique il n'y a absolument rien de
sorcier
je le fais à toute vitesse c'est devenu
une routine pour moi
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut être
attentif
bien regarder pour ne pas s'emmêler les
pinceaux avec les bobines
il faut vérifier le titre du film et le
numéro du projecteur
cela fait 20 ans que je travaille ici
depuis 1990
[Musique]
quel est le film là que vous allez
projeter les source intarissable
de foi du folklore dans les quinze
républiques soviétiques de l'ancienne
urss
les thématiques de ses films était
plutôt variés mais c'est vrai qu'elle
était imaginé pour les touristes pour
leur offrir un panorama idyllique de
l'union soviétique
parce que tous nos films date de cette
époque oui il fallait que les gens aient
un aperçu du pays pour que les touristes
puissent voir comment on vivait en urss
[Musique]
oh
discret et pas autrement et ça aussi du
terrorisme comme un pistolet lanouf les
rockets est votée les apps de
pixmania mais pâtit
[Musique]
ici c'est le tableau de commande de tous
nos projecteurs
de tous les appareils du cinéma
panoramique
[Musique]
on évoque chez tout quintette à vent ce
cinéma était un terrain d'essai pour
toutes les dernières nouveautés c'est
ici contestait les nouveaux équipements
bref tout était neuf ainsi alors que
maintenant le cinéma a l'air d'un
dinosaure
[Musique]
chaque séance on a un genre de mini
stress car les problèmes arrivent
toujours par surprise samedi dernier
tout allait bien tout fonctionné et à la
première séance de dimanche ça ne
marchait pas voilà on a été contraint
tout bonnement d'annuler monde a relancé
trois fois de suite les projecteurs et
ça n'a pas marché
[Musique]
il
en
[Musique]
vous devez être fiers de travailler
quand même
en effet ce lieu est légendaire encore
aujourd'hui les gens se montrent
intéressés par ce lieu quand ils
viennent ici soit le passé réapparu
devant leurs yeux soit il le décline
aujourd'hui des gens sont venus avec
leurs enfants et leurs petits enfants et
ils ont regardé les femmes elles nous
ont remercié à la fin le jeune homme
nous a dit il faudrait tout numériser
pour que cela reste pour les siècles à
venir
ce mot la numérisation je n'arrête pas
de l'entendre mais bien sûr si on
numérise est alors le côté rare de la
projection disparaître
un jour ou l'autre inévitablement cela
va disparaître parce que la pellicule
n'est pas éternellement
je pense que ce cinéma et passéiste mais
il ne veut pas renoncer il ne veut pas
mourir on peut considérer qu'il peut
s'estimer heureux d'être encore en état
de marche aujourd'hui
après la salle préhistorique de moscou
lente et dans la neige l'amérique
raconte son histoire du cinéma sur ses
longs bords de route
dans les années 30 l'américain moyen
découvre tout ce qu'il est possible de
faire dans sa voiture mangée faire ses
courses et voir un film voilà comment
ont surgi plus de 4000 écran blanc posé
au milieu de nulle part les fameux drive
c'est dans un état conservateur garant
de certaines vieilles valeurs
américaines le texas qu'il en reste 16
alors bonjour quel film robin des bois
amat is it c'est combien ces six dollars
ok
c'est l'écran numéro deux là bas ok 88.3
ok c'est la station de radio pour
écouter le film bonne soirée ok merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
m
bienvenue dans un gros clichés avec ses
speakerphone datant des années 40
[Musique]
l'amérique des drive-in c'est ce qu'on
appelle ici l'americana ans résume
hot-dogs apple pie chevrolet une
véritable façon de vivre où l'on
n'hésite pas à conduire deux heures pour
aller voir un film et chaque week-end
des milliers de voitures remplissent le
terrain vague du galaxy
les heureux propriétaires se sont eux
martin et marc chamard
de passionnés qui ont bâti eux mêmes
leurs drive in
[Musique]
ok et comprendre les gens viennent de
tous les horizons
beaucoup viennent aussi avec leurs
enfants c'est très libre personnes
nécessitent savoir si le tablier comme
il faut se comporte comme il faut
il ya aussi beaucoup de gays et de
lesbiennes et qui aiment cet endroit
parce qu'ils savent qu'on ne va pas les
regarder travailler voulait juger ici si
vous voulez boire une bière de voir un
film c'est possible si vous voulez fumée
voir un film le problème c'est
tranquille est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui viennent ils font
l'amour ici
de temps
[Musique]
pourquoi vous aimez venir ici
revenir dans un drive in c'est comme ça
un voyage dans le temps
en plus c'est là que ma femme et moi
avons eu notre premier rendez vous ok il
ya 25 ans
vous aimez voir des films ici oui c'est
beau
c'est romantique ça peut être commenté
c'est pour ça que vous emmenez votre lit
oui c'est ça
[Musique]
vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut oui je
crois les hamburgers l'époque comme des
bonbons les boissons la radio
martin pourquoi tu as envie de
construire ton propre driving
quand j'étais au fond j'y allais souvent
avec mes parents j'adorais ça à cause de
leur travail j'ai voyagé à travers tout
le pays et j'ai assisté à la destruction
progressive et doit lever mais je savais
qu'il ne restait quelques années alors à
partir de pièces détachées d'anciens
drive in j'ai construit mien pour faire
partie du mythe moi aussi mais quand tu
sais j'aime les vieilles voitures j'aime
les gens c'est la meilleure façon de
combiner les deux
je pense que les années 50 c'était la
plus belle époque aux états unis et je
veux que donner cette impression aux
gens ici
alors si vous voulez voyager dans le
temps il faut venir ici
[Musique]
cet effet comme très difficile de
résister aux multiplexes
on essaie d'attirer un public
complètement différente les gens qui
vont au drive-in ne vont pas dans les
salles et s'ils ne sont pas ici c'est
qu'ils sont chez eux devant leur
télévision beaucoup de gens viennent ici
pour profiter du restaurant mais en plus
ils ont spectacle qui va avec téléfilm
alors toi tu aimes les cinémas oui j'ai
toujours adoré ça bon on n'a pas trop le
temps de voir des films parce qu'on
ferait tout le temps et toute la nuit
[Musique]
on
ni mon travail comme la bnp
et
je
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
à bamako au mali il n'y a pas de mots
tels les des canapés qui pousse au bord
de la route
mais ici on peut également se faire une
toile à la belle étoile
[Musique]
dans les années 90 le mali comptait 60
salles de cinéma aujourd'hui il n'en
reste que 5 tout à bamako équipé de
matériel en très mauvais état
pas de siège luxueux ni pop corn mais
quatre murs un ciel ouvert car il fait
toujours beau
un rectangle en béton pas en blanc en
guise d'écran et des chaises en métal
[Musique]
dans un quartier populaire le cinéma el
hilal serre en plein jour de salles de
sport
bon
et la nuit tiécoura fait des miracles
avec des bouts de ficelle et de
l'ingéniosité il projette depuis 15 ans
le même film américain en 35 mm mais pas
seulement
[Musique]
mais le cinéma alors oui ah oui là oui
mais si moi c'est mon métier c'est mon
premier métier bon c'est moi l'amour
y est rude et c'est l'humain
bon les appels lancés les appareils
cayenne c'est marco russ à l'afrique
nous on voulait sa part elle n'a pas su
la france émotion et tristesse et moins
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup bien sûr là dedans on
paie pas on peut pas trouver d'accord
ces moyens qui modifiait les
pièces adaptables
[Musique]
le plus un territoire de libye
j'ai un problème de son bon ça donne pas
comme comme il faut je peux regret ça là
mais il ya plus de temps donc quand je
cherche des appareils la cause des
saints
on sait depuis
on a dû ouvrir
maintenant comment ils sont trop vite ce
crime la bombe a obligé m
l'épousé terme elle devrait présenter à
la région ne fait pas ça c'est ça que
les gens vont passer ses lois c'est ça
le cinéma ça sert des cinémas
je
le plat
la découverte
lui
qu'est ce qui se passe après le film
allant vous mettez quoi un deuxième
tient somme c'est un film porno pas sur
les petits enfants là à paris le 22e
mais son prix là c'est à cause de ça on
commence avec un 3e
23e chez nous ici de promotion pour le
grand simplement interdits aux moins de
18 ans a fait venir les gens ça oui
s'ils ont des familles ne peut pas
regarder un film pas moche oublie ça
c'est impossible avec les enfants c'est
impossible dans lequel ils sont obligés
de venir ici pour regarder des films
pornos
bon on dit mieux le son
à cause des bazennes
deux voisins
[Musique]
j'oublie
pendant que le porno se cache derrière
les hauts murs de bamako calcutta la
ville des cinéastes indépendants
débordent de créativité
ici il y à un réalisateur un peu fou qui
fabrique ses propres films et les
montres dans son minuscule cinéma de
quartier
c'est lui l'homme en bleu céline baba
toutes les semaines il se rend au marché
avec son sac rouge en plastique pour
faire ses provisions
bonjour s'allume
m
j'ai quelques bons films cette semaine
jetez un oeil bah oui je suis venu voir
ce que tu avais de nouveau
[Musique]
je regarde les bobines j'essaye de voir
s'il y a des scènes intéressantes
il me faut une bonne séquence de combat
une autre avec des dialogues est très
important une belle chanson puis je
regarde l'état général du film
ça fait 40 ans que j'achète mes films à
ces gens là
ils vendent des films kg ou alors on
peut acheter une boîte avec bobine pour
15 roupies
ses bobines ce sont des chutes
ou bien des pellicules en mauvais état
destinée hors au but il récupère auprès
des distributeurs
[Musique]
et
donc des films sont pas terribles cette
semaine les jeunes veulent voir des
nouveautés si je veux qu'on cinéma
marche bien je ne peux pas me permettre
de projeter trop vieux films bon allez
je te prends cela quand même
tu es notre unique client dans le
quartier à projeter des films comme ça
alors revenir respect prochaine et on
s'assure qu'on aura de meilleurs films
[Musique]
je suis en train de regarder quelles
sont les scènes les plus intéressantes
je n'ai pas besoin de projeter le film
je récupère tous directement sur la
pellicule
et ensuite je vais découper tous les
passages intéressants
donc là je vire ce morceau je coupe un
peu de ce côté un petit peu de l'autre
côté
voilà
et maintenant je vais pouvoir coller les
deux scènes qui m'intéresse ensemble
il faut bien aligner les deux morceaux
j'ai appris cette technique avec un
projectionniste
j'utilise du scotch normale
dans les cinémas il utilise un scotch
spécial
plus large mais moi je prends du normal
parce que c'est moins cher
vous voyez le scotch à boucher un trou
de la pellicule alors je vais le refaire
avec une lame de rasoir
en fait à partir de long métrage je
fabrique des résumés de films qui ne
dure que sept ou huit minutes et dans
lesquels on ne voit que les scènes
principales
c'est une sorte de bande annonce et
c'est ce que je projette dans mon cinéma
et les gens sont contents autant les
jeunes que les vieux en regardant ça ils
trouvent leur compte se distraient avant
d'aller au travail ou de rentrer chez
eux et en plus si vous allez dans une
salle ordinaire ça vous prend deux
heures de regarder un film et ça vous
coûte environ 15 roupies alors que moi
je vous montre tout en sept minutes pour
seulement une roupie
il
[Musique]
c'est ton fils oui c'est mon fils et ça
c'est un autre fils wayne lui aussi lui
et puis lui n'est qu'un frère et fils
ils me suivent depuis qu'ils sont tout
petits
ils ont tous appris à faire marcher ce
vieux projecteur russe comme un père de
ses enfants les quatre fils ont
développé un amour pour ce projecteur
ils ont le sentiment qu après mon départ
ils ont le garder et continuent à le
faire tourner et ça ça me touche
beaucoup
c'est pas qu'une question d'argent le
cinéma c'est notre passion à tous et ça
c'est notre histoire
et quand la nuit tombe la maison se
transforme en home cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
non
à 1700 km de calcutta à malaga où vit un
autre cinéaste roi de l'illusion et des
trucages
[Musique]
chaque nation en digne descendant de
georges méliès tourner des films avec
trois fois rien et un super héros
quelle scène tu va tourner la
superman a repéré un gros voleurs
doivent poursuivre
arrivé ici en volant et les enfants vont
courir devant lui
bon il me faut un vélo à il y en a un là
passez moi ton vélo
t'as pas de slip en dessous
[Musique]
qui a fait le costume
c'est moi
je les fais avec des scratchs pour qu'il
aille à tout le monde
[Musique]
l émission chaque mission s'affiche sur
sa super remontent du coup il sait où il
doit voler
et vous les enfants venez là
mettez-vous devant lui
action
mais
[Musique]
m
allez bouger plus la capte les gars
qu'on ait l'impression qu'ils veulent
ici c'est notre ligue ou d'ânes ou en
multi on a réussi à construire notre
petit monde moderne
[Musique]
a réussi à créer une association de 200
300 personnes et selon les rôles on a
différents acteurs
ce sont les mollets ou d'artistes
hollywood bollywood et maintenant molly
woods est dans notre mot les goudes
tchèque nasir et notre james cameron
quand je regarde un film sérieux et
final ça me fait marrer et du coup j'ai
toujours envie d'en faire une comédie
film d'action à une durée limitée alors
qu'une comédie dure dans le temps par
exemple on se souvient tous des films de
charlie chaplin
les films de nassir c'est beaucoup plus
que de simple remake son principe c'est
de prendre un film qui a du succès et de
mettre en avant les problèmes qu'il ya
dans notre village
par exemple si c'était spiderman qui
donnait des explications sur comment se
propage la grippe a et comment l'éviter
ça aurait certainement plus d'impact
[Musique]
oh
et
la cour suprême ndiaye
on est où là
on est devant le cinéma mohan c'est ici
que sera projeté superman ces films sont
toujours projeté ici oui c'est ça on y
va oui elles ont dit
et les villageois doivent payer pour
voir tes filles ou pas
oui et c'est 20 roupies la séance
il ya 900 places ici et chaque film
passe plusieurs fois par jour
les séances commencent soit trois heures
soit 6
[Musique]
après l'inde et ses super héros je
découvre la sibérie et murmansk
la ville des sous marins nucléaires et
d'un autre genre de cinéma plus
alternatifs
un cinéma qui ressemble au climat
glacial
murmansk est typiquement post soviétique
avec industrie à l'abandon et population
alcoolisées qui errent dans une
atmosphère en biais ce qu un décor idéal
pour faire des films ici aussi coûte que
coûte
[Musique]
[Rires]
voilà c'est dans ce trou paumé où la fin
du monde semble proche que se taire une
génération agissant librement très loin
de toute nostalgie et de la réalité
autoritaire de poutine
lui c'est ostap érudit alcoolisées quasi
aveugle jurant comme un charretier
lui c'est alexander penseurs aux cheveux
longs frisés ensemble ils réalisent des
films de série z avec en toile de fond
un cinéma abandonné au milieu j'ai des
souvenirs d'enfance qui sont liées à ce
lieu c'est ici pour la première fois
j'ai vu le film culte cosmico
fantastique soviétique à travers les
ronces vers les étoiles
et puis j'aime bien cet endroit
il s'en dégage une atmosphère à la fois
sinistre et envoûtante
[Musique]
kato
oui
[Musique]
un film somme c'est un gros salaire le
film est double
il raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme
qui est devenu fou après avoir lu un
livre
il est un peu dingue ils voient des
apparitions et ensuite la figure de
méphistophélès lui apparaît
la scène que nous filmons c'est quand le
jeune homme vient d'avoir une
hallucination est pris d'un accès de
folie et décide d'étouffer sa petite
amie mais elle ne se laisse pas faire et
s'échappe enfin ça c'est dans les
grandes lignes
[Musique]
nous puisons notre inspiration dans
différentes sources le cinéma est l'une
d'entre elles
je regarde toutes sortes de films mais
mes films préférés sont les films
d'horreur italien des années 60 à 80
juste egytiens
les films de dario argento mario bava
lucio fulci et de très nombreux autres
c'est un culte que je vous de manière
très personnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que moi pour être inspiré pour
écrire ou pour inventer des histoires
je regarde des films soviétiques pour
enfants c'est je vois beaucoup de vodka
après avoir vu disons cinq films dans la
nuit quand j'ai une bonne gueule de bois
alors c'est à ce moment là que les idées
naissent
parce que le cinéma soviétique pour
enfants à vrai dire c'est un truc
terrifiant
bonjour ça et chevêche astucieusement
et le soir à mourmansk c'est dans une
cave qu'alexander et ostap montrent
leurs films
bien à l'abri sous la glace il célèbre
l'aune de ground et le cinéma
[Musique]
son bien finir
non
[Musique]
mais
non
j'ai dit ouais ok
avant je travaillais dans un cinéma à
severomorsk
c'était il ya longtemps quand j'étais
jeune
j'ai fait ça pendant 15
ans suit j'ai projeté des films dans le
ciné club d'une unité militaire
hors aides au général c'est un métier de
femme quand j'ai commencé ce métier il
ya trente ans c'était déjà un métier de
femmes
probablement parce qu'il est mal payé
[Musique]
on
les motiver
[Musique]
oui oui
josé socrates a
passé vous passez votre boîte en
question
des minarets
croyez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à chaque cinéma son histoire et à chacun
sa façon de faire tenir à tout prix sur
la toile une invention datant de plus de
100 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si certains résistent dans leur salle
d'autres continuent d'apporter le rêve
aux spectateurs comme le faisaient les
frères lumière en 1895 la séance coûtait
alors un franc
[Musique]
cet article a été publié en 1964 j'avais
cinq ans quand j'ai fait tourner ce
projecteur pour la première fois c'était
un film indien dans ce lac quand mon
père m'a vu il m'a frappée car j'aurais
pu mais les cro q t il était occupé à
autre chose alors j'ai mis la bobine
j'ai démarré le moteur et c'est comme ça
que j'ai su comment ça marchait à partir
de cet instant j'ai toujours su que je
ferais ça toute ma vie depuis que je
suis petit ça me fascine
et combien de personnes peuvent voir un
film ici
il y à 12 trous de chaque côté et deux
devant vingt-six personnes peuvent donc
voir un film est selon l'âge et la
taille il y à différentes places à
différentes hauteurs
ensuite on tire sur les manettes pour
ouvrir le trou et pour voir à
l'intérieur
tant que ce n'est pas ouvert personne ne
peut voir c'est une manière de contrôler
[Musique]
et tout est mécanique mais comment vous
faites pour que ça fonctionne bien
ce sont mes oreilles qui guette le sont
et qui me donne le rythme
[Musique]
ce que vous voyez c'est le plus jeune
fils me dit qu'on est ça s'appelle mais
là il date de 1948
[Musique]
e
on travaille ensemble depuis toujours et
pour nous il n'est pas concevable de se
séparer notre vie c'est ça projetée du
rêve dans les rues
[Musique]
non
comment
et vous accueille
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oui
aulas
allez
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
et
vous savez on a une belle anecdote qui
est que les gens de toutes les religions
relais film que nous projetons c'est une
façon de dire que le cinéma s'adresse à
tout le monde qu'il n'y a pas de
frontières c'est mon père qui avait
trouvé ce nom et je les gardais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]